have you picked up resident evil 7 yet  well pretty soon there will be DLC  waiting for you too I'm Tony in this  game spot news update comes with extras  resident evil 7 has two expansions in  the works band footage volume 1 includes  a new bedroom escape scenario a wave  based survival mode and a standalone  experience called Ethan must die vol 2  includes a gambling scenario featuring  Lucas Baker a goofy minigame where  you're tasked with feeding jack baker  and a prequel that shows the family  before the events of the game you can  get both volumes with the $30 season  pass or put out 10 bucks for volume 1  and 15 for volume to the band footage  expansions are coming to ps4 first with  volume 1 on january 31st and volume 2 on  februari 14 xbox one and pc will get  both volumes on februari 21st if you  want to dig deeper into the games check  out our reviving Resident Evil series on  gamespot and for all the latest horror  video game news you're already in the  right place  you